existem muitos desperdícios nesse
momento acontecendo no mundo um
desperdício por exemplo é a falta ou o
desperdício de água
outro desperdício por exemplo
além disso de alimento
outra desperdício a quantidade enorme de
recursos naturais sendo desperdiçado
agora tem um desperdício entre entre os
recursos naturais fala pô
é o desperdício de talento humano
a quantidade de gente hoje em dia
trabalhando no que não quer e não
aproveitando nenhum terço do seu
potencial é absurdo e ao mesmo tempo nós
temos crises mundiais
o mérito
que necessitam de talento humano
necessita de esforço engajamento para
solucioná lo
em algumas crenças que suportam essa
inércia esse desperdício de talento
humano uma primeira por exemplo é as
coisas são assim mesmo não vai mudar
eu tenho esse trabalho e é isso aí vai
de repente na próxima promoção vai
melhorar ou a próxima reestruturação de
uma segunda criança que é não sou capaz
isso não é para todo mundo eu aprender a
transformar a vida para alguns não é pra
mim a gente passou quase sendo treinado
a olhar pra que a gente não é bom
os outros são melhores do que a gente
e tem uma terceira e principal crença eu
acho que é a cultura do medo está tudo
montado o procedimento
nossa esse de errado se eu não conseguir
pagar as contas e se eu falhar
há oito anos atrás eu estava exatamente
nessa situação
ea pergunta que tinha batia dentro de
mim é que eu vou fazer
como é que eu saio dessa inércia e desse
desperdício do meu talento
só que na hora que olhava pra mim olhava
para o lado e vi um monte de gente
também nessa mesma situação
o que fazer nessa hora e foi essa
pergunta que originou o conceito do
empreendedorismo
o que que é empreendedorismo
empreendedorismo é o processo de
reflexão de propósito e você colocar o
seu propósito em prática
desenvolver competências e pra são
inconscientes
esse é um conceito que nasceu dessa
inquietação e nesses sete anos a gente
vem experimentando esse conceito com
milhares de pessoas
é claro que a gente não tem uma forma
porque não existe uma forma cada um tem
uma jornada
cada um tem uma história mas ao
trabalhar com essas milhares de pessoas
a gente foi descobrindo cinco princípios
fundamentais do empreendedorismo
os princípios são abrir incluir
colaborar horna e acreditar
vamos lá o primeiro princípio abrir
abrir tem a ver com abrir suas
perspectivas olhar para dentro de si
olhar para os outros olhar pra
possibilidades abrir para novas
experiências para novos indicadores
precisa abrir a possibilidade a única
forma de se descobrir propósito é fazem
agora se a gente não experimenta se a
gente não percebe o que a gente está
fazendo nada adianta fazer um monte de
coisa tão abre essas perspectivas e
possibilidades
desde que eu comecei essa jornada por
exemplo
hoje em dia eu trabalho com quatro
organizações diferentes e têm projetos
na área digital na área de inovação na
área de educação na área de artes
a inovação aí a inovação da abertura de
possibilidades no cruzamento dessas
áreas de conhecimento diferentes
o segundo princípio incluir incluir tem
a ver com a sua capacidade de fluidez na
hora que se abre para a possibilidade se
vai entrar em contato com caminhos que
às vezes parecem desconexos
por exemplo eu preciso olhar para dentro
ou para fora
eu preciso controlar ofício ser livre e
no mundo de 2000 da dis de poli
polaridades que a gente tem ali dando a
gente precisa fluir entre essas
prioridades
por exemplo eu comecei minha jornada
como marketing profissional de marketing
depois fui caminhando experimentando e
virei facilitador
depois eu fui experimentando e virei
coaching
aí virei empreendedor
aí
virei palestrante
aí virei olha acho
e recentemente virou escritor que eu
faço hoje em dia todas essas atividades
agora algumas pessoas olham a vontade
está perdido de palhaço empreendedor
escrito em ver que na verdade tem uma
confusão enorme
hoje em dia com a palavra foco o foco
nesse caso é o propósito
agora a gente vai fluir em diferentes
atividades ao longo da nossa vida para
cumprir esse propósito
o último princípio é colaborar colaborar
tem a ver com a gente vai lhe dar nossa
jornada do empreendedorismo com
obstáculos complexos a gente está
enfrentando problemas cada vez mais
complexos
o aumento da conectividade as coisas vão
ficando mais complexas e portanto não
basta minha inteligência ou só a
inteligência dela
na verdade precisa do cruzamento das
diferentes inteligência pra gente
conseguir enfrentar esses outros tópicos
como diria nelson mandela
juntos somos mais fortes
agora a gente não foi programado também
para colaborar
tudo que a gente lida com muitos
empreendedores e tem uma vozinha e
aconteceu comigo também né
eu tive uma idéia nossa vou falar pra
ninguém
se não vou roubar uma idéia
só que se você faz isso no final das
contas está impedindo sua idéia
mas e se você colocar em prática
inclusive das outras pessoas dialogar
enquanto ideia e ajudarem a colaborar
construir a sua ideia
portanto para caminhar em direção ao
propósito é preciso se juntar porque
assim ficamos mais fortes próximo
princípio e um dos meus favoritos
a urna com esse isso com esse sotaque
nem com essa província é pra quem pede
diferentes localidades horna pra quem
não sabe a definição a horna tem a ver
com combinar tornando pra mim mas também
mas ornar com este ué e se essa
pronúncia muito mais do que o combinado
é coerência é verdade a integridade
à medida que a gente vai caminhando em
direção às possibilidades e ao nosso
propósito
a gente vai percebendo o senhor não orna
o experimento esse caminho o nuno morna
comigo eu converso com relato é
construir relações e órgão morning
e de novo aí os outros princípios
ajudando a fluidez você experimentar
essas coisas eu costumo dizer que eu
prendedor smo é um processo de um
encontro de você com você mesmo com a
sua luz e com suas vulnerabilidades
o erro faz parte do processo e também a
gente não foi treinado
vai rolar eu o longo dessa jornada errei
várias vezes já que vai errar
eu adorei esse mantra que eu que me
falaram recentemente já que você vai
errar é rápido é rápido se aprende
rápido e vamos pra frente
então como é que é sua capacidade de
lidar com essas vulnerabilidades o inter
feito também o que é um erro
a linguagem do palhaço por exemplo é
algo que a gente vem usando e que eu
encontrei e por isso que me tornei um
como uma grande forma de me desenvolver
no ano próximo o princípio acreditar em
você precisa acreditar primeiro em você
não é um exercício tão fácil acreditar
nos seus talentos nos seus valores
acreditar nos outros você vai encontrar
pessoas que você nunca viu
você vai precisar acreditar nelas para
porto o propósito em prática e acreditar
em algo maior
o exercício de ir em direção ao seu
propósito é um exercício de fé
honestamente em alguns momentos essa
jornada tem uma vozinha dentro de mim e
disser que estou viajando né
foi lá só que à medida que vem essa
vozinha ao mesmo tempo vem o acreditado
no faz sentido
e aí é como todos os princípios se junto
porque à medida que você vai
experimentando você vai fluindo outras
pessoas vão aderindo a essa jornada e no
final das contas você vai sentindo se
tornando num então se a vozinha dizendo
será que eu tô louco se começa a se
perceber perceber ao seu redor e percebe
que está fluindo
anos atrás eu tive o privilégio ea honra
de dar à luz a rede o ubuntu de
empreendedorismo e desde então eu vejo
várias vários várias campanhas dizendo
vai tira a bunda na cadeira vai fazer o
vento na rua ou vai fazer né
vai lá e faz e de verdade a gente
concorda eu apoio bastante essas
campanhas porque isso é muito importante
assim tão importante quanto fazer e
também é o autoconhecimento é refletir
sobre o que a gente está fazendo e se
perceber neste processo
o empreendedorismo é essa a filosofia
esse jeito de viver de você fazer e se
perceber fazem e ter auto consciência
há sete anos eu dei à luz a esse filho e
há sete anos vem outras pessoas ajudando
a criar esse fim
agora como todo filho
o filho do mundo
um é teu e recentemente a gente percebe
um movimento
de ele esse filho ter e criar sua
identidade
verdadeiramente viver sem identidade
se começa a ver o conceito de
empreendedorismo se conectar em outras
cidades com outros projetos com outros
países até e portanto este ano para
ornar com estes princípios
a gente abriu
a ação para funcionar como uma rede
verdadeiramente para incluir todos
aqueles que querem colaborar com a
construção desse sonho que sonho é esse
o sonho de democratizar autoconhecimento
o sonho de fazer com que todas as
pessoas olhem pra si e à medida que elas
olham para dentro delas automaticamente
olham
os que estão ao seu redor e olham para
os ambientes onde estão e aí sim a
transformação vai acontecer
confesso que esse exercício de desapego
não tem sido muito fácil
algo que faz muita gente acreditar
o que faz a gente acreditar é uma
filosofia que os africanos nos ensinaram
muita sabedoria
essa filosofia
se chama o bumbum
c é e você é porque nós somos obrigado